as the Mandalorian season 3 pivots
toward Ahsoka all these storylines
headed to their own crossover film
directed by Dave filoni thrawn is being
played by Mars Mickelson who voiced the
character in Star Wars Rebels and
brother to Galen urso actor mads
Mickelson the character was last seen in
Rebels on his Star Destroyer the Chimera
disappearing into hyperspace with Ezra
Bridger thanks to a group of pergol
hyperspace whales now you probably
picked up on bits and pieces of thrawn's
backstory but let us all now get on the
same page what is thrawn's real history
and why is he so desperately needed in
Star Wars right now well I'm gonna break
down drawn's publication history and
legends literature his returns and
Rebels and live action and what exact
role he's going to be playing in these
upcoming titles simply put thrawn is the
smartest tactician in the Star Wars
universe and we need him to expose how
dumb everyone else is so that they can
prove their heroism wise up finally and
truly earn the affection we feel for
them don't get me wrong I love these
soft knees but they've just been getting
off easy and I think filoni knows it
he's about to hit everyone with the fist
of a chiss
[Music]